yeah hi my name is malter I'm working
for Blue Yonder and I would like to talk
to you about paradoxes in model training
and evaluation under constraints so
those are paradoxes that I encountered
in customer projects I'll be talking
about unconstrained probability
distributions that will look quite
familiar about constrained probability
distributions that look a bit funny at
the beginning but we'll get into that in
a moment and a lot about strawberries
because strawberries that's our light
Motif we're talking about forecasting
strawberry boxes sales so we're not
selling the strawberries by the kilogram
or the pound or the piece but by boxes
and strawberries are a great example for
an ultra fresh product so unfortunately
they need to go to waste in the evening
um the strawberries that came in the
morning are either sold or they go to
waste so these our uh this is our
forecast for the number of salt straw
Strawberry boxes and when the actual
sales come in they look like this and we
are a little bit unhappy happy about it
because it looks like we have a
systematic over forecasting overall and
especially in this time range here it
seems that our model is not particularly
good because it didn't find at all that
on this day and on that day nobody
bought any
strawberries we would look into the
model we would look at features at the
data uh until we eventually look at the
process and ask a question maybe the
strawberries just went out of stock and
there were no more strawberries to buy
to check that we can super impose the
capacity so now in Orange we have the
capacity that was set in the morning so
the number of strawberry boxes that were
available for sale and uh when the
capacity was hit so when strawberries
went out of stock on that day we have a
red dot here so we see that we ordered
systematically too few strawberries here
um and feel that in the number of sales
and on those days it's not that nobody
wanted to buy strawberries but there
were simply no strawberries delivered uh
in the
morning so we see um that it's important
to distinguish between the unconstrained
demand forecast so like how many
strawberries uh are being asked for by
customers and the constrained demands
that is the sales so the strawberries
that are eventually bought by customers
and that's the difference so this is a
situation U that you will often
encounter uh in retail and of course you
want a meaningful training and a
meaningful evaluation that takes into
account the constraints and getting
there yeah involves a little bit of
probability Theory a little bit of
expectation values that sometimes take
slightly uh convoluted expressions and
of course what you want to have is a
shortcut here but what I would like to
uh convince you in this talk is that if
you try such a shortcut very often it
will be quick but it's a bit too dirty
and you'll end up with a simply wrong
training and a wrong evaluation that
will mislead you and I'll try yeah to
convince you to take the slightly longer
route and that this route is actually
not that
complicated so I will first introduce
our Workhorse so there these are the
upper sensored probability distributions
for constrained demand we'll learn why
this shape is uh what it is we'll then
see what can go wrong when we train
models on constraint demand and finally
how to evaluate models on constrain
demand so let's start with upper
sensored probability distributions and
with the question what does the demand
prediction of 9.7 strawberry boxes
actually mean because we don't want to
say that on a given day with such a
prediction you will sell nine strawberry
boxes plus 0.7 of course but implicitly
what we mean is that the expected mean
Demand on such days will be 9.7 and what
is implicit and um is taken here to be
the pon distribution is that there's a
certain distribution of what the demand
could be so we assigning every uh demand
value of a number of sold boxes a
certain
probability now this blue line here is
the expected value of the unconstrained
distribution if we now have a
constrained then things change a little
bit and here this is what you would see
the sales um uh at a capacity of 13 so
for 12 and Below we don't have any
change here but since we can never sell
14 or 15 or 16 or 17 boxes of
strawberries all the probability mass of
these events is added to the probability
mass of selling 13 items so a sales of
13 could be due to any Demand Being 13
or 14 15 16 and so on and this is why
it's called a censor distribution we are
censoring information when we observe 13
we don't know whether the true demand
was 13 or maybe 20 or
25 so let's have a look how the capacity
impacts the expected sales uh in the
situation I keep the expected demand to
be 9.7 so I have always the same uh
stock or the same situation and I'm
actually changing the stock so I'm going
from a capacity of Zero no stock at all
to a capacity of 25 and when this
capacity is very small then we are very
likely to just sell all of it and my
expected sales match my capacity when
the capacity is very large or much much
larger than the expected demand well
then I will just sell those 99.7 on
average and the capacity doesn't really
matter and then I have some region in
between which is quite interesting
because here I yeah sometimes we'll hit
the capacity and sometimes not and I can
make this more explicit by looking at
this capacity hit probability or like
the outof stock
probability this is very high when the
capacity is low so um if I have a
capacity of zero or one or up to five
then I'm very likely to hit this
capacity and the constraint distribution
looks like this so yeah with 96%
probability I will sell five items which
is saturating this capacity in between
like for capacity of 10 um I have 50%
chance to hit the capacity uh the
expected sales have shifted a little bit
to the left down from 9.7 to 8.6 um but
I can still see part of the probability
distribution here and if the capacity is
very very large so much larger than the
expected sales and like Beyond any
reasonable value in that probability
distribution then it doesn't have any
impact anymore on on my sales so you can
barely see that the probability to sell
21 was pushed down from a finite value
down to zero the probability to sell 20
was slightly increased and if you round
it down then uh this still um equal to
zero so now we have all the the
ingredients but what's also important to
acknowledge is like the order of which
they they appear so in practice you
would use an unconstrained demand
forecast like this one to actually set
the capacity so this is the input to the
planner who then decides okay on that
day we want 50 boxes of strawberries or
75 or 110 or so and this capacity
together with the unconstrained demand
forecast can then be combined to get the
constrained sales forecast so we have a
rate a mean rate we then also have the
capacity which itself depends on this
rate and then probability distribution
for the number of sales uh yeah which
has this particular shape here because
of this of the
sensoring and in practice or what we
will observe is a random sample out of
that constrained probability
distribution and we see that what we
want to learn namely this um is quite
far away from what we eventually
observed and we do constrain
sales so let's see what that means when
we train models on constraint demand so
we might run into very different
situations here so the first situation
is that the capacity is just hit every
day well then we never know the true
demand because we never know um if there
has been only one unhappy customer or
maybe no no unhappy customer at all that
didn't get to buy strawberries or maybe
there were hundreds of customers who
didn't got uh get to buy strawberries
and thankfully this will not happen uh
in in practice if you have sufficient
Supply because you would have so many
unhappy customers what the data
scientists really like is if the
capacity is just set to a very very
large value and we are just so certain
to never hit it to never go out of stock
that we know that uh sales reflect the
true demand this is nice for the data
scientists but uh compliance and
sustainability in fin
departments will come and say this is
not a VI viable solution here because so
many strawberries need to go to waste in
the evenings so what we will deal with
in practice is the capacity is hit
sometimes sometimes we see the true
demand so a mixed situation like that
one it's unavoidable to go out of stock
from time to time if you uh want to
avoid lots of waste uh it's unavoidable
to sometimes have some waste if you want
to avoid going out of stock every day
and we see the first dilemma here that
is um the situation that is optimal for
operations that you like as a retailer
because it's um it is the balance
between out of stock and waste this is
not optimal for data science I mean data
science wants to be in that situation
here and in projects what I often
encounter is that people say ah let's
not split hairs and let's just use the
constrained sales as an approximation
for the unconstrained demand it's it's
going to be fine it's going to be okay
but if you do this then you get an under
forecasting model and you get more and
more capacity hits and this is not
really the the way you want to go so why
why is that well let's look as um at
this example again a true demand of 9.7
at a capacity of 10 if you repeat this
many many times you would expect a
probability distribution like that one
from which we want to learn the
unconstrained demand of 9.7 but if you
just interpret this as true demand you
will learn the expectation value of this
constraint distribution so namely this
this red line here which is at 8.6 so
it's not a VI viable way to just say U
the constrainted sales um are a good
approximation for unconstrained demand
if you hit the capacity more than a
couple of times the next step that I
often encounter is that uh people then
say oh let's just train on the days on
which the capacity was not hit so let's
truncate this distribution in technical
terms let's remove all those capacity
hit events and keep all the green dots
um and and train on that and if you do
this uh and you again have a substantial
amount of outof stocks you will keep
decreasing the forecast and run into
even more outof stocks so you again get
an under forecasting model so why is
that let's go back to the example
truncation means I'm actually removing
the uh this data point from uh my
training set so I'm training on this
left hand side of the distribution which
has an expectation value which is even
further to the left at around uh 7.5 so
uh instead of learning what we want to
learn namely 9.7 we learn something much
much smaller around seven and the reason
for that is that if we do the selection
here we're inducing a bias by the
selection procedure we are getting a
hindsight bias um that uh yeah will will
then reflect uh in in the training this
is that is if I select days on which the
capacity was not hit I'm automatically
selecting days with a lower than typical
demand I'm selecting days on the left
hand side of the probability
distribution so I really re need some
methods for truned data for example
stats
models so let's now assume that uh we
train the model on constraint demand and
apply the correct uh procedures here uh
we will then want to evaluate them and
ask whether everything worked out fine
and the main question that I would like
to look at here is is the model biased I
mean we want to avoid to have a a biased
model because uh we want to have the
right balance between uh waste and out
of stock and how to not evaluate it um
yeah is is is pretty clear if we just
hold the mean observed sales against the
mean unconstrained forecast they will
defer very much and it's hard to say how
much they should
defer um and we already know the
solution to that I mean we need to
compute the expectation value of the
constraint distributions instead so we
need to make this constraint explicit um
to to then see whether it it matches to
mean sales and what I often encounter
here is that people ask me oh why why do
we need to do this in such a complicated
way because in our system we don't even
have have the exact capacity we don't
know whether we have 50 boxes of
strawberries in the morning or 60 or 70
we only know whether in the evening we
went out of stock or not so the only
thing that we can do is we can segregate
by capacity was hit against capacity was
not hit please let's do that and
evaluate from there and if you do this
here you again see that this numbers
simply don't match even though
everything in this talk is always a
perfect forecast and everything um like
in in a toy toy model so again the mean
actual sales and the mean unconstrained
forecast they don't match neither in the
case when I select uh day days with
capacity hit nor when the capacity is
not hit so why is that the case well
again we are just inducing a bias when
we uh select on hitting or not hitting
capacity so if I um ask for the expected
sales when the prediction has a certain
value and the capacity is hit if I
evaluate evaluate that well then I will
just find the capacity itself so I will
not learn anything at all about the
forecast about the forecast quality in
that case I will just reproduce um the
capacity setting strategy for the days
on which I have hit the capacity so I'm
really not learning anything at all
about my forecast if I condition on not
hitting the capacity I can write down
the expectation value and get some
convoluted expression here um and but
the important part is
that the expected sales will always be
smaller than a predicted mean so we will
have the impression that we are um over
forecasting but the Gap actually depends
on the capacity itself so again we have
a very very strong dependence of the
numbers that we see on the capacity that
we have set ourselves in the system so
without knowing how we have set the
capacity there's no way in saying what
we should expect um to from from these
numbers and what is the right number to
compare it
to so we know we need to compute the
expectation value under constraint and
in this case it then turns out to be
18.18 which nicely matches uh the the
the mean sales that we also
observe and what then often happens in
projects is that people say okay we are
convinced that the model is globally
unbiased I mean on global level this
works out but I still doubt that all all
these capacity hits are necessary I mean
I still think that on the days that the
capacity was hit there was some under
forecasting and this is why we have hit
the capacity so let's let's do this
segregation again and uh look at the
data by only capacity was hit or only
capacity was not hit and let's now look
at the mean constraint forecast and if
if you do this you will see that again
it does not match the mean sales um this
difference here is actually significant
and um so again we we we can't have the
expectation that the mean sales matches
the mean constraint forecast if we have
group by that and the reason for that is
again that if you select by the capacity
was hit or the capacity was not hit you
are selecting atypically large or
atypically small demand values um and
these are not representative so again
you are like selecting rather the left
hand side of the probability
distribution or the left hand side
realizations of the pro probability
distributions are the right hand side
realizations of the probability
distribution so you don't have an
unbiased sample here that you're
evaluating so the bias that you see
might very well be induced by your
selection procedure and uh not by by the
model
itself so still it's very very valid to
ask the question do we have outof stock
under control do we hit the capacity um
as often as necessary or are we totally
blind with respect to that and I would
like to propose to evaluate by predicted
capacity hit probability so how would we
do that so in this ska plot here I have
on the x-axis the predicted capacity hit
probability for all the different days
in a large synthetic data set so that
probability can be anything between zero
and one it's a continuous variable so
any value in between is allowed and on
the y- AIS we plot the actual capacity
hit and that's a binary variable so so
it can only be zero or it can be one and
nothing in between and now from this
geta plot you can't really learn too
much I mean if we predict say 0 five
then sometimes we hit the probability
sometimes we hit the capacity sometimes
we don't hit the capacity um to evaluate
whether those probability predictions
make sense we can first um aggregate
over the entire data sets to take the
mean over all predictions and all
outcomes um and then validate that we
predicted a bit more than 80% of
capacity hit overall and we also observe
a bit more than 80% of capacity hit and
if you want to uh dive a little bit
deeper what then makes sense is to
bucket the data into buckets of very
similar um capacity hit probabilities so
here we have the bucket of capacity hits
around 5% so predicted capacity hits of
around 5% 10% 20% 30% % and so on and
essentially we have a binary classifier
here and we can evaluate this binary
classifier so when we predict 40% we
expect to see 40% of capacity hits and
for this synthetic data set here this is
actually the case so the the size of the
bubbles here reflects how many events
are going into the respective bucket so
we see that most events here are at a
very large um cap Capac hit and just a
few here and so this is the picture that
you expect when your model uh is perfect
and very much in general it makes a lot
of sense to be forward-looking when you
evaluate forecasts so take the
prediction group them by some um
Criterion on the prediction and then
evaluate the mean outcome per prediction
because that's easy to compute often one
starts to do backward looking things so
one selects extreme outcomes and one is
then surprised that these outcomes were
underestimated or overestimated but by
selecting those extreme outcomes we are
again selecting the left hand side or
the right hand side of the probability
distribution so we are inducing a bias
by selecting by
outcome so this brings me to the end of
my talk I have a few take-home messages
the most important one is of course
please take constraints seriously if you
have a finite capacity don't ignore that
don't set demand equal to sales unless
unless you are really really sure that
you never hit the capacity and capacity
is not a problem for you when you
evaluate Group by prediction don't Group
by outcome so in other words don't look
back from an outcome what could have led
to that outcome um but look forward
given a set of predictions does what
happens eventually match these
predictions and think probabilistically
um if you ask questions like How likely
is it that we run out of stock or I want
to um order as much stock that my out of
stock probability is pushed down to 2%
or to 1% if you ask such questions you
need probabilities you need probability
distributions you will not be able to uh
deal with such requests using just a for
Point forecast that gives you um the
best estimate but does not make any
statement about the distribution yeah
and finally simulate the ideal clean
case first um everything in this talk
was within sandbox like toy environment
uh I took one very simple distribution
the pon distribution everything was
under uh yeah perfectly controlled
conditions uh and even here at least my
intuition was sometimes challenged so I
think we first need to understand like
the simple case and then we can go out
there uh into the actual world where for
example retailers will tell us well we
don't know what is the stock
start capacity on on a given day and we
will very often not know did we really
go out of stock or not maybe also some
strawberries are being stolen and many
other real world uh
complications uh that will make data
science uh challenging but also fun yeah
I hope this was uh useful for you if you
have any question please feel free to
ask
them uh we got a question I'll go ahead
and show it on stage
um do you recommend any python packages
for this sort of truncated distribution
analysis uh yeah yeah so so steps model
um has
uh uh has a fitting method for for
truned distributions indeed um there are
unfortunately uh While most commercial
packages also offer uh fitting of sensor
distributions I haven't found any python
package that does that um I wanted
myself to maybe add to to scipi to at
least have the sensor distributions
handy um that you can work with them in
scipi um yeah so stats models would be
the the the the first starting point um
yeah but I I hope that there will be
some some more open source contributions
uh in the next month or
years and then another question from
Julia
um Can solvers accurately predict
this um yeah yeah so I mean you uh in a
sense when when when you censor you are
always removing information so there is
I mean you're really you you have from a
data science perspective definitely a
worse situation when you have a finite
capacity than when you have a full
capacity I mean everything here was like
under full control and essentially we we
we knew what was the truth um so yeah I
mean you you can work around sensoring
and truncation and uh you can work with
maximum likelihood techniques and so on
but yeah you you will have a worse uh
model performance if you have finite
capacity it's removing information the
information is gone
um yeah you can circumvent it to some
extent but but not not
perfectly